[Applaudissements]
oui on va passer à bilal hassani le
jeune chanteur youtuber qui représentera
la france en mai à l'eurovision cette
année à tel-aviv et je vous le dis moi
c'est mon coup de gueule du jour dont on
parlait tous ensemble les jours un gros
coup de gueule à passer pas un jour ne
passe sans qu'on le parle de lui alors
pourquoi bill al hassani suscite il
autant de haine on en parlera avec vous
autour de la table mais juste après ce
petit récapitulatif en images c'est
parti on ira alors qu'il est le nouveau
visage qui va représenter la france lors
du prochain concours de l'eurovision
bilal assadi ne fait malheureusement pas
parler de lui que pour sa musique
âgé de seulement 19 ans ce jeune homme
d'abord découvert sur youtube puis dans
the voice a connu une rapide
médiatisation en participant aux
qualifications de destination eurovision
ouvertement homosexuel son look
androgyne que certains décrivent comme
courir fait son originalité et a tout de
suite marquer les esprits alors que
certains ont soutenu la démarche du
jeune homme d'autres se sont permis de
l'insulté et ont déversé leur haine à
l'encontre de bilal quelques jours plus
tard c'est une caricature du journal le
midi libre qui a fait polémique
un dessin dans lequel bilal assadi se
retrouver la tête sous une guillotine en
référence à la chanson mon roi qu'il
interprète une caricature qui n'a pas
fait rire tout le monde et qui a été si
mal reçue que le journal s'est
finalement excusé nous ne voulons
évidemment aucun malhabile al hassani je
suis désolé si ce dessin a pu choquer
nous n'avions pas cette volonté cette
semaine sur le plateau de morandini live
c'est guillaume et l'a dit le
coprésident de l'association urgence
homophobie qui était invité pour évoquer
ce sujet julien aubert par exemple qui
est un des plus de 2
vaucluse je crois répond un article qui
titre la raba la perruque en finlande
village vous regardez vous êtes une
honte de la république
vous êtes la honte des républicains et
franchement vous devez des excuses
publiques à bilal mardi matin nikos
aliagas avait fait le choix d'inviter
dans la matinale d'europe 1 le jeune
homme accompagné de sa maman qui a
témoigné de la violence des attaques
dont est victime son fils je le protège
tout simplement en lui en lui disant
tous les jours que je laime nous avons
porté plainte parce qu'il faut rappeler
que nous vivons dans un pays où il ya
des lois qui interdisent le harcèlement
sur les réseaux sociaux plus la
polémique enfle plus les positions des
différents comptes durcissent alors
selon vous pourquoi bilal assadi suscite
il tant de haine alors dites nous voilà
ce qui se passe autour de jeunes hommes
voilà qu'on connaît beaucoup qu'on avait
reçu ici et il ya plein de dessins
satiriques y a plein toute la journée on
ne le lâche pas voilà sera mon coup de
gueule dans un instant francesca est ce
qu'on peut être honnête oui ce que je
bats on veut pas ici on est scellé c'est
les minutes de vérité s'appelle pas les
8 minutes de f1 de la marque que je
pense ce qui est un véritable regain de
l'homophobie en france on l'a vu avec
des actes physique des agressions
physiques homophobes qui ont eu lieu
partout en france à lille à bordeaux et
on voit aussi des regains effectivement
on voit aussi des regains de haine et de
messages aux folles sur les réseaux
sociaux
et ça on peut que le constater c'est
gravissime c'est aussi ça qu'il subit et
moi ce qui m'a profondément choqué c'est
cette une du midi libre
parce que franchement on va la prendre
en compte un sens cette guillotine
après un peu de mal à aimer l'argent
alors non mais je vais vous dire alors
le midi libre le mise à niveau alors
j'ai ouvrir pour ils ont fait ça c'est
parce que justement c'est pour dénoncer
parce que sa chanson s'appelle jean
vilar mois pour dénoncer voilà que le
roi on veut le guillotiner et sait pas
c'est pas contre bilal instance elle
rien compris mais j'ai bien compris
c'est le second degré et aussi qu'on
dénonçait le vélo faut lâcher de lui
tomber dessus
mais l'image est forte et moi
personnellement il me choque et en plus
j'ai dit ici sur ce plateau mois
l'origine je suis pas spécialement fan
de sa voix de la chanson et tout ça mais
je trouve ça scandaleux et absolument
gerbant et c'est vrai que tout ce qu'on
entend là c'est pas possible et
l'homophobie grandi en france il faut
qu'il y ait des moteurs à la limite on
en a toujours vues sur les réseaux
sociaux et dieu merci encore une fois
twitter n'est pas la france la preuve il
a été élu
heureusement
disque est à ce qui m'ennuie beaucoup
plus c'est quand on donne un peu de la
parole à des gens qui sont dans les
médias je pense notamment à philippe
manoeuvre qui a dit c'est la foire aux
bestiaux
c'est il faut il voit que la femme à
barbe pour aller à l'eurovision
maintenant à mes lui lui avez vu je
pourrais te gifle et les diables nuit ce
alors il est déjà venu ici ça s'est mal
passé
voilà enfin il était venu il avait dit
encore des conneries oui voilà de lui
d'ailleurs qui ont aussi cotonou
homosexuel on à la femme à barbe on
emmerde
voilà franchement et je trouve ça très
grave un gamin c'est un gamin il est en
train de ce2 de ce c'est un gamin qui
pour arriver des choses il a il a tout
mon soutien et effectivement il faut que
les médias soient du bon côté qui est
des cons sur twitter la plupart et les
médias comme nous doivent être du bon
côté c'est donner un exemple où les
médias sont du bon côté je suis désolée
elle a pas toujours mais des livres que
ses limites manoeuvres qui se marchent
sur europe 1 il m'a notamment pas partie
des médias manoeuvre on s'en fout mais
il appartient au monde médiatique à lui
en donne la parole pour moi il
appartient aux grenats parole a annoncé
ryan o'neal et plus rien tout s'est
étiré à midi et midi libre je pense pas
qu'ils ont fait sens de repenser balle
ne pas constamment ses pilotes
s'exprimer on raconte on les années
difficiles qu'il a vécus au collège et
au lycée
regardez ça comment ça a commencé encore
plus tôt que ça ça a commencé avant que
moi même je me rende compte de quoi tu
de quoi que ce soit par rapport à ma
propre personne et on faisait des bons
mais disait qu'ils étaient en fête et
autres insultes r on me disait voilà tu
es tu es gay
et puis moi je leur disais mais j'en
sais rien j'ai 12 ans donc laissez moi
tranquille s'il vous plaît
et c'était un petit peu difficile à
vivre parce que c'était s'étaient toutes
les années du collège on voulait
absolument me coller une étiquette que
je n'étais même pas misé moi même mis à
la base quoi oui j'ai là où il a tout à
fait raison et sa maman que nous
entendions aussi c'est de porter plainte
parce que seule la justice
mais lui donner raison parce qu'il ya
une sorte d'impunité dans les réseaux
sociaux je suis comme vous serrez les
réseaux sociaux c'est merveilleux mais
il ya des façades son nom mais il ya une
phase et sont donc il ya une phase
arrêtée
tout comme partout voilà exactement et
cette façon perverse qui apparaît contre
bilal elle doit être sanctionnée par la
justice les plaintes pour harcèlement
bien sûr ça va aller au bout les gens
seront sanctionnés y a plus d'impunité
contre non la porter plainte
oui et sachez que urgence stop
homophobie avec bien sûr mon ami
guillaume mélanie vont prendre tous les
frais d'avocats de bilad bravo à
guillaume que j'embrasse oui oui c'est
vrai que j'ai essayé de voir le verre à
moitié plein c'est c'est difficile dans
ces circonstances mais je m'inscris la
société a quand même bien évolué même si
évidemment il ya une réminiscence de
l'homophobie et je pense qu est limité
comme un secteur sorte de noyau dur
j'espère en tout cas là mais il ya un
prochain pas apache et c'est que il ya
encore boa passé c'est qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de personnes qui lisent
évidemment je tolère m'attend le léguer
ça ne me gêne pas du tout mais qui ne
revendique pas et ça sera peut-être la
prochaine étape c'est cuit il a le
malheur pour lui de revendiquer le fait
qu'il soit gay ouvertement qu'ils se
perruque et c est ça et encore beaucoup
de gens qui kiffent rennes à cause de ça
c'est grâce à lui que tous les dix ans
d'avancé et moi et moi je vous dis ça
horrible et bien moi juste moi juste un
petit truc à dire si lâché le quoi le
mec bien sûr au talent il va nous
représenter à l'eurovision on y est on
est tous avec oui moi je
espérons qu'elle fasse de logan mais on
regarde juste la prestation oui moi je
trouve voyager kg de fraises après sa
douche quand la chanson mine de rien
elle rentre dans la tête
elle est très bonne et surtout arrêtez
de me faire chier et à l'eurovision est
ce qu'on dirait un hétérosexuel est
alors au visage ce moment il était il
était tranquille me fait sa carrière il
emmerde personnes il a fait son show il
a très bien fait son show arrêtez de le
faire chier non mais c'est vrai
franchement lâché le sa famille on a vu
- selon le témoignage de sa mère qui
était poignant vraiment je vous le dis
vous croyez que c'est facile pour lui
pour sa famille toute la journée
elle prend des insultes même aujourd'hui
le pauvre c'est ça devait être un kif
pour lui ça devait être une fête devient
une galère donc lâché le laissez le
faire son travail
laissez-le nous représenter à
l'eurovision on espère qu'il va bien
figurer et celle qui va faire un carton
et on sera avec lui à fond et je vous le
dis est juste les personnes qui essaient
de faire le buzz aussi sur son dos
franchement mollo parce que fo le lâcher
dans messi allait m'appeler ya plein de
gens qui essaient de faire le buzz sur
ça sur le dos de bilal sais pas si vous
avez remarqué
laissez le travailler et pour moi c'est
avant tout un talon et il était
talentueux avant de faire ce concours
pour l'eurovision je peux vous dire que
c'est une star chez les jeunes et c'est
un modèle pour plein de gens moi je vous
le dit c'est un modèle pour plein de
gens c'est c'est vraiment cécile il est
incroyable ce qui fait donc lâché le
laissez le faire chanter
la culotte qui nous regardent mais
l'ajustement qui je fais un gros bisou
et j'espère qu'il verra nous voir
prochainement
il ya surtout beaucoup d'amour plein de
messages de soutien voilà c'est vrai et
notamment kelly notamment plein de gens
ici autour de la table et bilal joue le
taulier même mois il ya des choses qui
sont passés qui ont été dites dans une
de mes émissions que je produis que je
ne cautionne pas voilà même si j'aime
beaucoup voilà les personnes qui sont
dans l'émission de mathieu être excusé
voilà c'est ça où il a décliné mais
bilal sache qu'on est avec toi à fond
alors bilad ya quelqu'un qui a eu un
petit coup de gueule contre au lit c'est
pas ça n'a rien à voir et même essayer
maitena biraben puisque elle aurait
annulé sa participation à l'émission m
comme maïtena sur rmc au dernier moment
écoutez maïtena je devrais vous annoncer
que nous allons maintenant recevoir by
la nasa libye la guerre va représenter
la france à l'eurovision
mais il se trouve qu'il ya une heure sa
maison dit ce que nous a informés qu'il
ne participerait pas à notre émission
pour je cite rassurer sa participation
ce soir une émission de télé bon bah en
dehors du fait que ça ne se fait
vraiment pas je tiens à dire la maison
dynamisme de disques pardon que c'est un
manque de respect pour notre équipe pour
notre travail mais surtout et c'est le
programme pour les auditeurs de rmc et
bilal on embrasse aussi on souhaite le
meilleur on souhaite de gagner voilà
alors on peut comprendre aussi les
suppressions il est surexposé sachet qui
nous a une aussi de venir chez nous la
semaine dernière et on a tout à fait
compris qu'ils ne viennent pas et on
espère le revoir au moment de l'
eurovision concentre toi sur
l'eurovision a ri et j'ai un truc à te
dire laisse tomber n'écoute pas tout ce
qu'on dit les fonctions talent il est
indéniable et il ya plein de gens qui te
soutiennent et sachent qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de gens qui te soutiennent fille
que de gens qui sont contre toi
stoppé par le déferlement de haine
compter du temps il al hassani oui à 59
pour son nom à 41 et maîtrise de son art
mais c'est à dire ce que tu as dit c'est
fort c'est ça il doit se concentrer sur
l'eurovision et ne pas écouter ce qui va
se passer parce que la france est long
lem la france allait comme elle aime et
il ya des gens quand ils allument leur
télé on leur a dit marie myriam
l'eurovision france gall ils se
retrouvent avec bilal ça peut ça peut
déstabiliser des gens il ya la
méchanceté sur twitter on l'a dit et je
vous dis après il ya deux il ya ceux qui
sont pas fans de la chanson mais comme
tu as dit il faut vraiment qu'ils se
concentrent que sur l'eurovision et
c'est que mathieu l'a dit il va nous
faire gagner du temps il va faire gagner
du temps et ça va faire avancer les
trucs mais il faut qu'ils soient armés
dans sa tête parce qu'il va traverser
les âges qui va traverser
il a beaucoup de talent